It's time for Drew's News, your daily trip
to the good news castle.
With me at the desk, two good news knights
in shining armor.
Our favorite young reporter, Emmy Eaton.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
I'm so excited to be here.
And my other trusted co-pilot, Rossi Ross Matthews.
Hi, hi everybody.
I feel the exact same way as Emmy.
I'm so excited to be here.
All right, let's get right into it.
First step, we're going to Atlanta
to meet three tiny wieners living in big style.
Doggies!
I know!
This is the cutest.
Newsweek reports, a man named Benjamin Maser
is racking up millions of views for his mini living room
for his mini wiener dogs.
No, you guys, literally, this is all to scale.
It's the cutest thing ever.
All the details, tiny lamps, teeny tiny teeny tables,
a tiny flat screen, and there's art hung
at Wiener dog eye level.
Aw, come on.
And the coffee table is actually a salad bowl,
and the couches are perfect height
to protect their little spines.
I mean, what do you think about this story, Emmy?
I mean, I just love dogs because my dad,
he won't let us get a dog.
(Drew gasps)
Raise your hands if you guys out here think
I should get a dog.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
What kind dog would you wanna get, you think?
Golden noodle.
A golden noodle?
They're just the cutest.
What would you name your dog if you got one?
Well, our neighbor has a dog named Amber,
so we could name it Sapphire or something,
and they could be the two gem twins.
I'm sold.
I'm sold too, don't kill me, okay?
All right, Ross, your story next.
Well, Emmy, we're gonna go to your home state now
for some good news, you ready?
Yes.
Okay.
Well, this comes from the East Idaho News.
Last December, the Olsen family was struggling
to make ends meet.
And when the mom, Timanee Olsen posted a pic to Facebook
of her ugly sweater cookies.
Well, some people reached out to her.
They wanted to order some, and Timanee thought, "Why not?"
And then her secret talent blossomed.
The customer orders started pouring in,
and today she's got her own business called Cookie Momster,
and she's booked out six weeks in advance.
(applause)
You cannot get these cookies.
And she says this business has taken off
and has changed her whole family's world.
And I know you've tried her cookies, right?
Yeah, she made my birthday cookies.
They were just so cute, and, today I have a special delivery
for you guys!
No?
Lift up your yellow napkins.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
(applause)
Look, we have your podcast one,
and we have the tea.
I mean, there is a Drew's News,
there's an Olive and Frankie, a flower,
love the way you look.
I have to just say to Timanee, who is the Cookie Momster.
First of all, everything you're doing, Timanee,
is so clever.
The name is very clever.
How is that not taken already?
Brilliant.
And then the cookies you make.
I looked at each and every slide of her cookies.
You're really, you've got the goods,
and Timanee, we're gonna feature you
on our small business gift guide.
You are just doing extraordinary things,
and you are really so special.
Thank you so much
Awesome.
Timanee, for bringing
this to our attention.
(upbeat music)